the White House recently said as I told
you that it was ending that bogus voter
integrity voter fraud commission not
because they believed there was no voter
fraud I guess we're supposed to still
think that Trump believes there was
voter fraud I don't know what the guy
really thinks but we were told that they
were ending the voter fraud commission
because it was the states who weren't
cooperating with Trump and they weren't
giving Trump's commission the
information they needed to properly
investigate the voter fraud that's what
we were told I don't remember if it was
last week or a couple weeks ago that we
did that story two days ago the White
House did a court filing associated with
the data that they had collected for
this voter fraud commission and they
admitted that they actually had found no
evidence whatsoever of voter fraud now
you might say well hold on why would
they admit that they had to admit that
to justify the destruction of all of the
confidential voter data that some states
did give them so you might be saying
hold on last week they say the voter
fraud Commission is being disbanded but
the investigation isn't we're gonna hand
over the investigation to the Department
of Homeland Security and DHS is going to
take over but what is there to take over
if they are now saying there was nothing
in the data that suggested voter fraud
so we're going to destroy all of the
data it's a comedy of errors and a very
expensive one to taxpayers by the way a
quote from the White House director of
information technology Charles Herndon
he said the Commission did not create
any preliminary findings in any event no
Commission records or data will be
transferred to the DHS or another agency
except to the National Archives and
Records Administration if required in
accordance with federal law so this
differs not only from what we were told
when the entire thing started the day
after Trump's inauguration but it
differs from what we were told last week
and for us it's just confirmation of
what we already knew right which is
there was not voter fraud there were no
three to five million people who voted
illegally for Hillary Clinton it's all a
ruse to boost Trump's ego and make him I
guess try to make the case that he
really won the popular vote but to the
committed trumpet the absence of finding
anything is confirmation of the
conspiracy to screw with the election of
course you can't find evidence of it
because the people who did the the voter
fraud Pat they covered it up really well
so there's no evidence of it it's just
interesting to me because there is voter
fraud but it's just so few and far
between that yes significally
insignificant it's not going to sway an
election no doubt one way or the other
so couldn't they just locate a few of
those instances and just then blow that
out of proportion and use it with a
voter suppression what changed the
election and three to five million
people may have voted illegally maybe
but maybe they figured if we come up
with six cases when we said three to
five million people did it it sort of
gonna seem on unimpressive
but if you're waiting for those who are
fully committed to this theory to say
you know it didn't happen that's not how
it works the when you're committed to a
conspiracy theory
you see absence of evidence as evidence
of the existence of the conspiracy
that's just the way it works
I loved after the election the instances
of Trump voters who voted twice but we
have different states I mean now it's
just hilarious to me right yeah it's
it's disparate the voter fraud that's
taking place in person is
disproportionately Republicans trying to
show how easy it is to commit voter
fraud and very often getting caught and
getting arrested themselves because it
turns out it's actually not quite so
easy the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as $1
per month and every dollar helps to
support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad